philippe bas et bien votre bilan de ces
trois auditions sur ce deuxième volet de
l'affairé benalla sur les passeports
diplomatiques et notamment tout d'abord
et bien sûr cette bombe qui a été lâché
par patrick strzoda le directeur de
cabinet des manuels macron qui a dit qu
alexandre benalla avait utilisé une
vingtaine de fois ces passeports
diplomatiques entre le 1er août et le 31
décembre qu'à l'évidence ces auditions
étaient nécessaires et les informations
nouvelles qui nous ont été données
prouvent que l'action du parlement celle
du sénat en particulier est utile pour
que le pouvoir exécutif sont amenés à
prendre un certain nombre de décisions
et à rendre compte au parlement
ceci nous le faisons en vertu de la des
crasses de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen nous votons la loi
bien sûr mais nous contrôlons aussi le
fonctionnement de l'état et je crois en
effet que ce que nous avons appris
aujourd'hui notamment l'utilisation pour
20 voyages de passeport diplomatique
ce sont des informations très
importantes qui renforce encore les
interrogations que nous avons sur ce qui
a été fait par l'état pour que en
licenciant monsieur benalla on le prive
aussi de tous les attributs de son
ancienne fonction pour que le cordon
ombilical entre monsieur mais n'a là et
l'état soient rompus au fond et il n'y
aurait pas eu d'affairé benalla sidel de
mai dernier il avait été licencié il n'y
aurait pas eu ce rebondissement de la
sphère bénard si on avait été un peu
plus proactifs pour lui retirer ses
titres de voyage dont on activement sa a
pris énormément de temps plusieurs mois
pour lui retirer ses passeports
diplomatiques notamment elle passe pour
diplomatique et aussi les passeports de
service avons nous appris ça fait
beaucoup quand même de documents
auxquels s'ajoute un téléphone crypté
qui n'avait pas été rendue non plus et
dont nous avons appris aujourd'hui que
l'elysée s'était assuré que ce téléphone
crypté étaient devenus inutilisables et
que
il était désormais réclamer on appris au
autour du passeport de service qu'ils
avaient été obtenues par un document
peut être falsifiée je redis les mots de
patrick strzoda c'est un monsieur qui a
utilisé régulièrement défaut pour
obtenir des titres officiels
est ce que vous sentez aussi que
l'elysée ne protège plus du tout
alexandre benalla mais je ne me prononce
pas sur le point de savoir si les
protégés ou non
j'essaye de rester factuels ce sont les
fans start c'est que il a été très
difficile pour l'elysée de se séparer de
monsieur benalla et une fois que son
contrat a été rompu
les attributs de sa fonction ne lui ont
pas été aussitôt retiré et dans les mois
qui ont suivi on ne s'est pas donné
suffisamment de mal aux yeux de notre
commission pour qu'il lui soit retirée
si bien qu'il a pu utiliser apprend t-on
à de nombreuses reprises ces passeports
diplomatiques pour des voyages qui ont
donné lieu à des entretiens avec des
chefs d'état et on se demande pourquoi
un chef d'état étranger reçoit monsieur
bentalha avec des hommes d'affaires
étrangers alors que le président du
tchad et notamment le président du tchad
alors que monsieur banana occupait des
fonctions en apparence assez modeste à
l'elysée qu'est ce qu'on attend de lui à
l'étranger c'est au delà des pouvoirs de
notre commission que de se pencher là
dessus mais au fond comme représentant
de la nation
nous disons en conscience qu'on a le
droit de s'inquiéter de savoir pour la
défense des intérêts fondamentaux de
notre pays
ce que peut dire un ancien collaborateur
du président de la république dont on
constate tous les comportements qui ont
été décrits par le directeur de cabinet
du président de la république ce que
peut dire cette personne a des chefs
d'état étrangers qui défendent face à
leurs francs à la france leurs propres
intérêts une toute dernière question
alexandre benalla avait déjà été
interrogé sur les passeports
diplomatiques il a dit qu'il les avait
laissées dans son bureau et que c'est
seulement plus tard qu'un agent ne
lisais les lui aurait rendu d'évidence
est contredit par ce qui a été dit
aujourd'hui est ce que pour vous et bien
vous juger qu'il ya parjure est ce qu'il
faut saisir la justice sur ce point je
ne me prononcerai pas sur ce point avant
d'avoir entendu monsieur benalla j'ai
besoin d'expliquer autres addictions
trek mais la contradiction est évidente
il ya d'autres contradictions dans ce
dossier vous le savez bien mais celle là
est particulièrement visible
nous attendons des explications ou une
rétractation